welcome to Cambridge forum discussing
the rise of irrational ism I'm Pat
surkhi director of the forum which is
now in its fourth decade of bringing you
live public programs for the discussion
of the issues and ideas that are shaping
our world leading our discussion is
Wendy Kaminer lawyer social critic and
public policy fellow at the Radcliffe
Institute her articles essays and
reviews have appeared in The New York
Times Newsweek the nation and the New
Republic she is a contributing editor at
The Atlantic Monthly and The American
Prospect and serves as the president of
the national coalition against
censorship Wendy Kaminer has published
five books including I'm dysfunctional
your dysfunctional and true love waits
in her most recent book sleeping with
extraterrestrials the rise of irrational
ism and perils of piety she continues
her incisive and witty criticism of
contemporary American social life this
work forms the basis for our discussion
of the rise of irrational ism welcome to
Cambridge forum Wendy Kaminer
thank you all for coming I was at a talk
this afternoon and the speaker thanked
everybody for turning out on such a cold
day and I thought to myself what wimps
we've all become it's been 50 degrees
for the last two months and it drops
down below 30 for a couple of days and
suddenly we're patting ourselves on the
back for venturing outside but in the
spirit of the season I will thank you
for coming out on such a cold evening
I'm happy to be inaugurating the year
2000 lecture series at the Cambridge
form but I'm not going to be talking
about anything terribly new tonight I'll
be talking about something quite old or
in fact something rather timeless
religious faith I hope you don't mind
too much if I don't actually talk about
extraterrestrials these are good years
for religion and spirituality movements
as you know which means that in many
ways they are good years for social
critics and satirist as well stories
about the supernatural abound tales of
angels aliens conversations with god and
the spirits of the deceased adventures
in ESP and reincarnation all compete in
the marketplace with established
religious beliefs Donald Trump runs for
president what once seemed Surrey oh is
now merely mundane it seems as if the
surreal and the supernatural have been
domesticated and I think that's one
consequence of the rise of irrational
ism now when I talk about the rise of
irrational ISM I'm not suggesting that
human beings have somehow become more
irrational in recent years you'd be
hard-pressed to find any period in
history unmarked by unwrapped irrational
beliefs and behaviors but culture is
like real estate it is cyclical
sometimes reason is up and sometimes
it's down while religious faith and
magical thinking rain and for the past
two decades I think reason has been in a
downturn at least in popular culture my
critique of irrational ism is in part a
critique of the popular notion that our
society is excessively rational and we
need to put cold reason aside and
embrace our intuitive powers what pop
star
are feeling realities think with your
heart not with your head was one of the
mantras of the recovery movement pop
spirituality books like The Celestine
Prophecy which is one of my favorites
commonly denigrate reason as the last
refuge of the unenlightened the current
wave of religious revivalism which I
take to include new age and established
faiths encourages a similar celebration
of ineffable intuited truths truths
about the existence of God the reality
of heaven and other spiritual ideals
it's difficult to generalize about
religion and I think we need to be very
careful when we generalize about
religion because it takes so many
different forms and often embraces
deeply conflicting beliefs John Dewey
said we should never talk about religion
in the singular we should only talk
about religions plural and I think we
should talk about sectarianism a lot
more than we talk about religion but we
can engage in generalized discussions of
religious faith the willingness or
capacity to believed in deities angels
or miracles whatever form they might
take we can I think identify basic human
needs that are served by various
religions the craving for immortality or
for cosmic justice now I'm hardly the
first to observe that if there were no
fear of death there would be a lot less
religious faith it's obvious that the
promise of immortality greatly enhances
the appeal of Western religions and
contemporary new-age movements popular
spirituality books tell us incessantly
that there is no death either will be
reincarnated or transformed in some
mysterious higher form of energy will
start vibrating at higher and higher
levels the celestine prophecy tells us
or with the right attitude and diet we
might live in our current form forever
that's essentially one of the promises
that Deepak Chopra makes to us or
perhaps we'll just linger on as ghosts
in a more traditional form there are
many emortality options in the new age
established religions generally tell us
which Western religions generally tell
us that if we behave we will ascend to
heaven and according to a 1990 gallup
poll some three-quarters of Americans
believe that they are glory bound you
have to wonder who they think is
inhabiting the other place speaking at
Harvard recently at the Kennedy School
Billy Graham pointed out that when he
embraced Jesus his fear of death
dissipated and that's an obvious selling
point people seem most likely to believe
what they want to hear or what they fear
in either case emotion tends to preempt
reason so it's not surprising that that
terrifying accounts of alien abductions
coexist in popular culture with bedtime
stories about guardian angels who offer
us unconditional love guardian angels
have always seemed to me to be like the
perfect parents that people in recovery
might have dreamed of with faith on the
ascendant tales of the supernatural
enjoy considerable appeal we live i
think in very credulous times so when I
talk about irrational ism I'm talking
about kuchulu T gullibility I'm
concerned with the ways in which our
culture celebrates faith and D values
reason and applies habits of faith to
questions that require empirical
analysis notably questions of Public
Policy it is for example perfectly
appropriate to take on faith the
assertion that God loves you but it is
not appropriate to take on faith the
claim that ending welfare benefits will
end teenage pregnancies now of course
there are times when faith and reason
will overlap these are not to entirely
distinct realms sometimes we employ
reason to implement faith-based ideals
sometimes ideals temper a commitment to
logic and efficiency I'm not suggesting
that rational analysis requires that we
have no deeply held beliefs unless we're
strict utilitarians and I'm not most of
us choose values and ideals
instinctively they are for us articles
of faith we may not require proof that
murder is wrong but if capital
punishment is just fun
as a deterrent to murder we ought to
demand some proof of its deterrent
effect so I don't mean to denigrate
religious faith but I would like to keep
it in its place in general I think when
we're shaping and implementing public
policy are trying to understand the
physical world leaps of faith are no
substitute for empirical analysis
assertions about the divinity of Jesus
or God's covenant with Israel can only
be taken on faith but conclusions about
the efficacy of the war on drugs or the
power of Christian Science healers to
cure cancer ought to be demonstrated
empirically the irrational ism that
discourages questioning and empirical
analysis is one important and I think
often overlooked legacy of the
therapeutic culture and by therapeutic
culture I mean that ethics and values
derived from popular therapies notably
the recovery movement the 12-step
movement that flourished in the late 80s
and early 90s the therapeutic culture
exhorts us to substitute feelings for
facts to take personal testimony at face
value especially when it relates to a
searing personal experience like child
abuse if we cross examine someone
offering testimony of abuse or question
her credibility we're apt to be accused
of perpetuating or collaborating in her
abuse at the very least
cross-examination is considered a breach
of etiquette we're expected to judge the
truth of an assertion by the passion or
parents sincerity with which it is
preferred as if people were never
delusional or simply convincingly
dishonest we're supposed to take stories
about extraterrestrials guardian angels
ghosts and other supernatural
occurrences at face value as well and
the authors of pop spirituality books
depend on our willingness to suspend
disbelief and take them at their word
when they tell stories about
communicating with God angels or their
dead grandparents if you question their
stories you're apt to be dismissed as
someone who hasn't yet evolved
spiritually so the therapeutic culture
has given us a notion of
truths an ocean of knowledge that
focuses on feelings instead of facts now
of course there are times when
therapeutic truths or feeling realities
are appropriate in a therapist office
for example although it seems to me that
even therapists have to be quite
concerned with distinguishing between
historical and emotional truths an
assertion like my father never
understood me is a subjective emotional
truth that needn't exactly be tested but
an assertion like my father raped me is
presented as an objective truth it is a
claim about historical fact that needs
to be verified in my notion of a good
therapist is not someone who encourages
her patients to hold on to delusions
what are the dangers of confusing
feelings with facts consider the results
of importing therapeutic notions of
truth into the courtroom we saw a rash
of wrongful child abuse cases in the
1980s and 90s and the imprisonment of
people for crimes that probably were
never even committed these cases
reflected in part a failure of reason
and the confusion of justice with
therapy believe the children or believe
the women people said take their stories
at face value even when the stories were
unbelievable and some awful and justices
followed from that we saw the Emerald
case here in Massachusetts a courtroom
ought to be a realm dominated by facts
not feelings by reason not faith so when
I talk about the rise of irrational ism
in part I'm talking about an
inappropriate reliance on personal
testimony as a source of objective truth
I'm talking about confusing the realms
of faith and reason now I realize of
course that a great many people derive
enormous comfort and maybe even some
enlightenment from their subjective
intuitions about unverifiable spiritual
truths I don't deny or even address the
private benefits of irrational ism
including belief in supernatural
realities I'm interested in the
political legal and social consequences
of faith whether it's faith in guardian
angels faith in the ubiquity of
satanic cults or faith that Jesus Saves
I'm interested in what I think of as the
perils of piety so one general problem
with piety which I've discussed that
confuse the confusion of faith and
reason the rise of gullibility in
closing and I promise you this really is
in closing I want to address one more
specific and very familiar problem which
is the rise of sectarianism and the
marriage of particular religious beliefs
with government think for a moment about
the very showy piety of the current
presidential race one democratic
operative announced a few months ago
that the Democratic Party is going to
take back God this time making the
almighty sound like a child in a custody
dispute and soon Al Gore was confiding
to millions of Americans that he too has
been born again George Bush famous
famously chose Christ as his favorite
philosopher thinker and other Republican
candidates quickly followed suit
suddenly the media noticed that the
campaign was suffused with God talk but
it would be much more accurate to point
out that the campaign is the fused with
Christ talk general references to God
have always been part of our civic life
it's true that religious particularity
mainly evangelical Christianity has
occasionally intruded into political
campaigns most notably through Williams
jennings bryant in the early 20th
century but in modern America major
party candidates have generally steered
clear of such aggressive sectarianism
thank God you might say introducing
sectarianism into political life
introduces religious majoritarianism and
threatens the religious freedom of
minorities it's well worth noting that
all of the candidates who are indulging
in Christ talk are Protestants members
of the dominant faith I suppose you
could make orrin Hatch an exception to
that since he is a Mormon not quite a
dominant faith but for the most part
these are mainstream protestants and and
that is no coincidence it
it's almost impossible to imagine a
candidate for national office choosing
Mohammed as his hero instead of Christ
or advertising his Hindu heritage or
consider a simple and fairly recent
historical example when John Kennedy ran
for president in 1960 he had to stress
his belief in the separation of church
and state not his religious faith
because his faith placed him in a
minority and it was at the time a
somewhat suspect minority as a Catholic
Kennedy encountered religious bigotry he
needed to assure voters that he would
heed their voices and not the dictates
of the Pope sectarian rivalries always
underlie the relative Amity of our
diverse society which is one reason we
should be very wary of proposed new
partnerships between church and state
conventional wisdom tells us that
religious belief is essential to virtue
and so politicians are rushing to
confirm their support for what they call
faith based social services but what
they're really talking about our
sectarian social services the 1996
welfare bill contained what was called a
charitable choice provision that allowed
tax dollars to be given directly to
sectarian institutions for the
administration of welfare programs there
was a similar provision inserted into
the juvenile justice bill and in fact
there are provisions charitable choice
provisions being regularly inserted into
bills in Congress now into social
service legislation when people say that
they support voucher programs or
charitable choice provisions that divert
government money to parochial schools
and churches I think they're imagining
government funds going to the religious
groups that they like they're not
considering giving tax dollars to fringe
groups like the Hari Krishna they're
thinking about a welfare program run by
the Protestant church down the block not
an after-school program run by the
Reverend moon or the Church of
Scientology but of course if you
establish a government program that
gives money to sectarian groups you
can't simply give it to the groups that
the majority of americans approve of so
I suspect that programs like charitable
choice are going to inspire well
obviously they're going to inspire
competition among
nominations and I think they're also
arouse a fair amount of religious
bigotry people tend to forget that the
prohibition on government establishing
religion is essential to protecting the
free exercise of religion and in a way
it is also essential to our notions of
equality in public life sectarianism can
create two classes of citizens saved and
the unsaved George Bush has conceded
that he does not decide who will get
into heaven but I bet he thinks he knows
who won't thank you
you're joining us at Cambridge forum
listening to Wendy Kaminer discussing
the rise of irrational ISM Wendy this
country has always prided itself on
being a pragmatic can do pull yourself
up by the bootstraps kind of place how
did I rationalism gained such a hold
over our institutions in our population
today I'm always leery of statements
that start this country and then make a
generalization about what this country
is because this country is extremely
diverse and it is one of the pitfalls of
social criticism is is generalizing I
mean I'm guilty of a two we all tend to
generalize am in the business of
generalizing about the culture but I
always do try to qualify it our culture
is not monolithic there are a lot of
competing strains within it and so I
think the most you can do is talk about
what are the dominant strengths you know
what seemed to be the dominant strange
what are the dominant strains in the
popular culture that becomes easier and
easier to do as media becomes more and
more homogenized and tends to present us
with a picture of ourselves that that
may well be more homogenized than we
really are so you know I'm not sure when
you say this country has always prided
itself on being pragmatic it is it is
certainly true that one of the things
that that we tend to tell ourselves
about America is that we are common
sense can do nation and that's true and
we have this this one cultural tradition
of pragmatism and common sense we have
other cultural traditions to you know we
have a cultural tradition of
individualism we also have cultural
traditions of great conformity so you
know I you can't you can't characterize
us in any one way and how could how
could we not be in part irrational I
mean we are each individually naturally
irrational I mean I certainly don't
pretend to be an entirely
I am maybe not as irrational as most
people but certainly as irrational as
many people I i try to be vigilant
though about maintaining for myself what
I think are appropriate separations
between faith and reason so I you know I
we are always irrational this has always
been a common we that we have the strain
of pragmatism in the country we also
have a very strong strain of religiosity
you know we've gone through a periodic
periods of periodic periods we've gone
through many several periods of
religious revivalism in this country so
along with all the pragmatism and
materialism there's a lot of religiosity
and attraction to the spiritual realm we
had in the late 19th century a romance
with spiritualism you know which was
centered right here in New England so I
don't see it as at all contradictory
does that answer your question well can
you identify some of the factors talk a
little bit about this when you talked
about the legacy
therapeutic culture that have led to a
dominance of the irrational strength
these many layers in the time that we're
in right now I think the effect of the
therapeutic culture was really quite
important and I think it's fairly subtle
the notion of as I've said the notion of
truth that therapeutic culture offers us
the notion that you that when somebody
stands up and tells you a story and it
might be a story about some fantastic
occurrence that that somehow her
sincerity and her passion is is evidence
that the story is true I don't think we
can underestimate the influence of that
other explanations you know a lot of
people will say and there may be some
truth in this that the religious
revivalism we're in now reflects the
aging of the boomer generation which is
my generation and that feels like a very
bunnell explanation to me but you know
it doesn't mean that it's not true we've
certainly seen a rise of interest in
both established religion and new age
religions in the last 20 years some
people will say that it is in part a
reaction to new technologies and to
science and you know I I haven't I
haven't really figured out what the
connection is between technology but I
think that it it might well be there and
when I think about computers and and fax
machines and even it all seems like
magic to me I mean can you imagine
introducing a computer or a fax machine
to somebody in the 19th century it would
feel stranger to them then the
appearance of a ghosted seance it would
certainly appear as strange so you know
there's a way in which all these
technologies seemed almost magical I
think to a lot of people and I haven't
quite figured out what effect that has
on making other fantastic assertions
seem as if they might be real but I
suspect that there might be some
connection you do write in your book
about cyberspace II and you you do talk
talk it a little more could you expand
on that theme and talk a little bit more
about
what communicate electronic
communications technologies have done to
the concept of truth and to wellness of
communication in a Democratic Society I
don't know how much they've altered the
concept of truth but and this is not
this is hardly an original point there
is a great deal of information on the
internet there's also an enormous amount
of disinformation or misinformation and
it's very hard to know what the
provenance of the information is that
you get it and that's why when people
talk about this information age they end
up talking about branding you know what
are you getting it from Matt Drudge are
you getting it from CBS not that you can
necessarily rely on CBS you know do you
do you know the source of your
information it's extremely important to
know the source of your information I
had a friend who was teaching a class
here at Harvard who said that he had
students who were doing research papers
by sending out messages on the web
saying things like does anybody out
there know anything about
methamphetamines well you know maybe
you'll get maybe you'll get a genuine
expert who responds to you with some
good information and you know and and
maybe you'll get someone who knows even
less than you do so you know there's it
it demands that we become much more
vigilant in thinking about where our
information where our knowledge is
coming from how we're going to
distinguish between fact and rumor how
we're going to verify what's presented
to us in cyberspace as fact but the
other thing that interested me well
there are several things one of the
things that interested me about
cyberspace was the way people who are
very much immersed in the digital
culture talk about it and as I as I read
essays and interviews with with people
who are very much involved in this
people who have much more sophisticated
understanding of the technologies than I
do which is not saying much they sounded
very much like people from the 19th
century talking about
and cure there were echoes of 19th
century spiritualism when you read
people testifying to the wonders of this
great transcendent mind that's out there
on the net and and it sounds a little
like Christian Science it's really very
interestingly just the echoes of 19th
century New Thought spiritualism some
Christian Science that you can hear in
the way a lot of techno files talk about
cyberspace and I was just that was just
interesting to me one of the other
things that interested me was and this
is something that sherry Turkle has
written a lot about the way cyberspace
affects the sense of self and and as a
writer I'm interested in the way the
cyber culture is I think increasing the
incoherency in public discourse and I
think incoherency has something to do
with irrational ism when I was about ten
years ago in the late 1980s I was
teaching freshman expository writing and
i had so i found myself looking at these
writing guides writing rhetorics which I
had never looked at because I've never
actually taken a writing course in my
life and I was struck by the way these
writing guides were telling people how
to write and this was not long after
computers had become fairly common in
the student population and the
instruction was well you get your topic
for an essay and when you get your topic
think about five points that you want to
make and list them 1 2 3 4 5 and then
construct a paragraph around each point
and then look at all these paragraphs
and you know this is now all in your
computer and just you know start
rearranging them and think about the
kind of order that you want to present
them in and I was just I I was appalled
is too strong a word let's say I was
really quite discouraged by this because
it's it's a very different concept of
writing than the 1i
had its its I mean my own concept of
writing is I don't know how to describe
it except to say that it's more organic
I start at the beginning and I and I
developed something and I go through to
the end and I don't I don't write it in
pieces and I don't conceive of an essay
is a series of interchangeable parts
that I'm going to throw into my computer
and arranged in some way I began to
notice in the mid-1980s when editors
first got computers I mean that was a
sad day in some ways when editors got
computers because they started editing
much more aggressively simply because
they could and they started doing things
like you know moving transposing
paragraphs within an essay just because
if there was something that they thought
was sexy that was kind of halfway down
the piece they wanted to move it up
front so that you'd get the reader
immediately and they say well this is
sexy let's let's move it up here to the
second paragraph and you know in the
spirit of cooperation I'd say well okay
we can think about doing that but you
know once you do that then how are you
going to get from here to here I mean my
writing is fairly tightly constructed
and usually the end of one paragraph
leads into the beginning of the next
paragraph and that's something you know
I actually think about I think about how
the writing is going to flow I think
about what the sequence of thought is
and when you start just moving
paragraphs around without making
transitions and without having the
benefit of any of the natural
transitions that you've made while you
were just naturally thinking it through
you end up with something that's quite
choppy and into my mind incoherent so
I'd say well that's fine but you know
how are you then going to make this
transition from here to here and the
answer was always don't worry we'll drop
a space and I you know I as I say I
don't want to say I was appalled but I
was I was deeply discouraged by that if
you look at the average newspaper column
now it doesn't read like an essay
anymore it reads like a telegram it's
all short sentences one or two sentence
paragraphs I'm always fighting with
editors about trying to get you know
maybe a four sentence paragraph can I
just get four sentences in the paragraph
and mostly they're concerned about the
aesthetics of it they think that you
need to have a lot of white space on the
page or people won't read it if you have
too much print it's too daunting
for people this is not I know this may
sound like a digression to some of you
it but I don't think it's that much of a
digression if your question is about
irrational ism I think as I say that
what I'm talking about now is a is
incoherency incoherency in the way we
are writing which i think is going to
lead to some incoherency in the way we
are thinking and I can't help us think
that that has something to do with a
decline of rationalism there is the
school of thought of course that
believes that language is pre-programmed
in the brain in some way and that the
the kind of irrational thought following
from irrational speech that you're
fearing could not possibly happen that
our brains will save us from ourselves
well I'm not going to get into a fight
with scientists about that i'll just say
that i hope that they're right the ones
who believe that you're listening to
Wendy Kaminer discussing the rise of
your rationalism the floor is now open
for your questions and comments and
please do use the microphone in the
aisle
do you think that the widespread
expectation among large numbers of
people that a disaster was going to
strike at midnight on january first two
thousand is an example of rationalism in
the society well yes no you know if
you're talking about the people who
thought that we were going to be
witnessing the second coming you know if
you were talking about people who
expected some supernatural event I would
say yes that was somewhat irrational if
you're talking about people who are
worried about y2k I don't consider that
irrational there was reason to think
that a lot of computers would
malfunction we are very dependent on
computers you know maybe it was hyped up
but I think it's very difficult for the
average person who does not have a
sophisticated understanding of the
technology to be able to gauge how
serious this is going to be so I don't
think that the fear about computer
malfunctioning was at all irrational it
might have been in some ways
unsophisticated it might not have been
as well informed as it could have been
but I don't think it was irrational I I
asked my brother who was a computer
programmer you know if he thought I
needed to go underground I don't think I
put it quite that way but I asked him
what he thought was going to happen this
was about two years ago and he said well
it's hard to know you know it could be
absolutely nothing or it could be the
end of the world it could be a complete
disaster most likely it'll be you know a
few disruptions a few not very serious
disruptions like a snowstorm and I think
that was the information that a lot of
people were getting and I don't know how
you could I don't know how I would have
gone about independently investigating
that except to ask my brother who I
consider a fairly rational well-informed
person
as I was watching a Geraldo Rivera
program in which he was interviewing pat
buchanan and he was he was criticizing
pat buchanan because pat buchanan had
made some statement know the exact
statement but it had to do he thought
everyone should either be a Catholic or
a Christian i'm not sure but he thought
you know but then who would he have to
disparage well let me continue the thing
is that Pat Buchanan offered his opinion
that he is a religious man and he
believes what he believes and as a
Protestant even though even if he had
said he believes everyone should be
Catholic I wouldn't necessarily be
offended by that because I understand
that people of faith while they have
certain core beliefs that doesn't mean
that they necessarily hate people and
there's this assumption among humanists
that if you believe that your particular
sector is going to heaven and no one
else that automatically believes that
you hate everyone else and I think that
that's a sort of arrogance on the part
of humans because I see other people for
instance William Pierce who I would
consider to be a humanist taking it as a
prime e facie case because most wealthy
nations are mostly white that somehow
whites are superior therefore white
should just kill everyone else and take
over the world yes is it possible that
maybe there's a little bit of arrogance
on the part of hue
whoo-hoo assume this religious people
somehow want to hate her disparage other
people just because they have certain
core beliefs and I just I just don't see
that I don't see that with people like
Jerry Falwell anytime a question starts
is it possible the answer is almost
always yes you know in most cases but I
I would dispute your basic premise that
there is an assumption among humanists
that religious people who think that
their religion shows the one and only
way to salvation hate other people I
don't think you know let me at least
speak for myself what I don't I don't I
don't in infer from that hatred of other
people but I do here in that a sense of
superiority a sense of exclusivity if
somebody tells me that he's going to
heaven and I'm not I don't think he
hates me he may feel sorry for me he may
want to help me get to heaven but I do
think that he feels quite superior to me
now maybe he doesn't take credit for his
superiority maybe he feels that he's
been blessed by gods grace and I haven't
and and so you know maybe he doesn't
take credit for it but there's a feeling
of superiority and I think that feeling
of superiority is very can be very
dangerous in an elected official you
know I'm pap you can and is certainly
entitled to believe that Catholicism is
the one and only truth but it would be
would make me very nervous if we had
somebody in high office who believed
that his religious way was really the
only way I think it's very hard
believing that not to engage in some
sort of discrimination my name is James
Reid I've come up here from chatham
massachusetts for therapy tonight I
enjoy your books miss Kavanagh I think I
remember everything you've written
after he died in the early 70s I became
involved because I was teaching
philosophy here at Harvard with the
Bertrand Russell society it began with
it's just a couple people that enjoyed
reading the old curmudgeon over the
years within two or three years became
very very political very programmatic
very religious the same thing happened
with the American Philosophical society
and of late with Paul Kurtz's
organization that I was involved with
originally the Society for the claim
scientific claims and blah blah blah if
you say Machu Picchu I have palpitations
if you say extraterrestrials I faint if
you talk about Redfield in his book I
get very very upset the thing that my
question for you is you seem to have a
way in your book that does not inculcate
a feeling that you're a member of a
ferocious group I have no difficulties
with what I disagree with intellectually
I have a basic fear of a gentle and
genuine secular approach to serious
serious problems with American culture
becoming sectarian in some accidental
and most unfortunate way my question for
you and my therapy for tinnitus do you
have any guidance to keep organizations
like that from becoming too
self-important too regimented and too
angry let me make sure I understand your
question are you talking about what I
but I sometimes see in secular humanist
groups which is a kind of sanctimony I
am and a kind of sense of their own
superiority because they've seen the
like that there is no light and other
people think that there is one that is
that what you're talking about uh-uh you
know I'm oh I'm often stymieing when
people say do you have any guidance
because I very rarely do I'm much better
at
and offering criticisms and then
solutions you know I much better at
analysis than solving problems and I
tend to be something of a fatalist I
think that you know it people seem to
need to believe that one way or another
they have the truth whether it's the
truth that God exists or the truth that
doesn't God exists and that God doesn't
exist and it seems to be very important
to them to spread that truth you know I
don't even consider myself an atheist I
consider myself an agnostic you know I
consider the existence or non-existence
of God just one of those things that I
just can't even think about you know
what how would I possibly know about
that and I think it's not even in many
ways a relevant question in my life you
know it's not it's not my business to
think about whether or not God exists
it's just my business to go about trying
to live a decent and honorable life so I
you know I don't even consider myself an
atheist much less a militant atheists I
don't have any evangelical impulse
myself you know I have no desire to even
try to persuade people not to believe in
the things that they believe and I and I
think that the effort would be
completely futile anyway I i guess i
would like people to examine the way
they believe which is a little bit
different and that's what I try to write
about but you know do I have any
suggestions for how to keep people from
getting arrogant about their own beliefs
you know I don't I never know what to do
except to counter what they say with
what I say to say what I think if I'm
with them in a group to try to nudge
them a little bit you know I can't think
of anything programmatic that one might
do but i don't think i understand the
problem that you're talking about
it seems to me that if you get into
discussions of rationality or
irrationality uncertainly rationality
this is very much dependent on the
ability to use logic and the example
that you described with the editor
review as sounds like you know it's
going to become a self-fulfilling
prophecy in the sense that here you get
the deconstruction of logic I mean logic
doesn't come in in milliseconds sound
bites or something so there seems to be
this inability really to think along the
lines that you would like people to
think and this really seems to be pushed
on us by the media by the culture by
everything and and by by the cyber
culture yeah and I wonder also then what
happens is you would regard to this last
question that was asked you were talking
about I don't have a problem with what
anybody believes as long as they don't
try and push it on me and what this
brings up is this question of this need
for certainty in certain people in
certain groups and it's almost like they
can't be certain unless they burn me at
the stake for my beliefs or something
like that and that's where I think we
need to draw the line certainly in this
country because we're not a theocracy
and I was wondering if you could sort of
comment on some of these things let me
take your first point about illogic I do
think that the kind of editing that I
was talking about before it does
contribute to the decline of logic and
that's why I brought it up and one of
the things that makes me uncomfortable
about the cyber culture and the prospect
of hypertext you know if people using
linkages jumping around a lot is that I
see it really as the death of argument
because to construct an argument you
need readers who are willing to read
something without interruptions you know
you need undistracted readers readers
undistracted by linkages you need
leaders who will stay with you as you
develop an argument as you lay out the
logic along with the information and I
think that's going to become
increasingly hard to do but let me not
be arrogant about this because I don't
want to assume that
this kind of logical linear
argumentative thinking is the only way
of being intelligent and I and what I
suspect is that we're going to see new
kinds of thinking and new ways of being
intelligence that might come out of this
culture that you know I can't begin to
describe because I can't even imagine
them and I feel like something of a
dinosaur because you know I I'm very
much attached to a certain kind of
traditional analytical linear thinking
but I really don't assume you know I
don't assume that my way is the only way
to salvation I don't assume that my way
is the only way to be intelligent or
even rational I just don't know I can't
quite imagine what's going to replace
that let me get to the second part of
your question which was I think really
about sectarianism about how we keep
people from imposing their religious
beliefs on people who don't share them
that has been a constant struggle for us
really throughout our history and it's a
battle that we have to fight all the
time you know we're fighting it right
now in Texas in a school prayer case
there are there's a case going before
the supreme court involving the power of
the schools to have more or less
official prayers at football games the
question was more like this need to
certainty on the part of those
sectarianism who impose their belief
system I think that's just dial it's one
of those things that I got is human
nature up gage because they fear that
this then you have it all but I don't I
don't even address the way people are
fundamentally and I think you're talking
about the way people are fundamentally I
think this need for certainty is
fundamental and a lot of people I think
what we address is the way those needs
are translated into law and policy and I
think that you know at least for me
that's the battleground that I've
it out on and so when we have
sectarianism rising up whether it's
school prayer whether it's a judge
putting the Ten Commandments in his
courtroom you know we fight it we fight
it in every case we fight it every time
we can when it comes up and I do think
that there is a general sense in you
know for all of the problems we have I
think there is a strain of religious
tolerance that we can fall back on and
that is is pretty widely felt you know
this there was a proposed amendment
school prayer amendment to the
Constitution that came up in Congress a
couple of years ago and it was pretty
soundly defeated in the House of
Representatives and it was defeated by a
coalition of secular and religious
groups but there were a number of
religious groups more liberal religious
groups but genuinely religious groups
that were opposed to this school prayer
amendment because people realized that
there are a lot of different prayers out
there that people want to say and you
really don't want the school board
imposing one prayer on a diverse group
of students Wendy some of the comments
you make tonight we're helpful but some
of them still leave or open-endedness
the nature of these type of discussions
I just want to draw attention to a
couple when you're talking about things
like keeping faith in its place or not
confusing the realms of faith and reason
suggest there's some sort of pre defined
boundaries that we can look to for where
these are and i'm not sure where those
necessarily our who gets to draw them oh
when they were drawn and then the
illustrations that you would give along
those lines particulars we got to faith
would indicate to me more of a
privatized marginalized aspect of faith
and well i guess i want the second part
my question would be do you see faith
having any public face to it at all and
where would that be oh I think
absolutely faith has a public face to it
faith is what provides people with their
ideals and I that's what I meant to say
when I said that you know for me you
asked me where's the dividing line
between the realm of faith and reason
you know I that's something that we're
always going to be arguing about and and
that's I think an important public
discussion that's and I don't know if
there's anyone answer or one ever
changing answer but that's something
that we need to decide for ourselves and
try to reach some consensus on that for
me the general rule is that when you're
looking at questions of public policy
when you're looking at that questions
about the way the physical world works
that you're mostly in a realm of reason
you know if you're thinking about if you
think the drug abuse is a problem and
you want to figure out how to end it you
don't take on faith that putting people
in prison for 15 years for low-level
drug offenses is going to solve the drug
problem you need to look at those
problems those questions empirically so
that's a kind of general rule but if you
ask me where I think faith comes in
faith comes in in motivating people you
know the most obvious example in the
example that people always give is the
civil rights movement for many people
that was a faith-based movement it was
certainly a movement with a lot with a
great deal of religiosity and a lot of
conviction and a lot of passion came
from people's religious faith but I
think it's also important to remember
that civil rights movement didn't make a
religious appeal to America it made an
appeal to secular constitutional notions
of fairness and equal justice so it's
you know it's a mix faith motivates
people faith gives people passion it can
bring them into the public sphere but
but once they're there I think to be
effective they need to use a language
that is more secularized or at least
non-sectarian if they're going to draw
in the rest of us does that answer your
question in part yes okay no okay
either short question maybe long answer
stepping you've written about you've
talked a lot about irrationality and
ordinary life everyday life if you step
into academia and particularly
philosophy departments if you noticed
any varying range of rationality and
irrationality well you know I've
succeeded in never stepping into a
philosophy department and and maybe that
shows you just how rational a person I
am I think the best example of
irrational ism in academia in recent
years was post modernism which which
really celebrated by celebrating
celebrating subjectivism you know
telling us and this is this bit quite
reductive what I'm going to say now it's
quite reductive it's quite simplified
but I think it will do essentially
telling us that you know there aren't
any objective realities that mostly we
have to rely on our own subjective
perceptions and so you know for a while
I've seen that every time somebody gave
a talk in academia you know she begin by
deconstructing herself and telling us
you know breaking herself down
demographically and every which way so
that we could know exactly where she was
coming from so that we could evaluate
what it was that she was saying and I
think this reliance on on the subjective
which characterized post-modernism is
very similar to the reliance on a
subjective that you find in the popular
therapeutic culture and I think that it
is essentially irrational it always
amuses me to see academic trends
mirroring that the you know what's going
on on Oprah mirroring trends in popular
culture yes you have mentioned that
school prayer and charitable choice
provisions are areas of public policy
affected by rationalism what other areas
of public policy would you say are in
serious danger of being affected by
irrational is amar well I wouldn't say
that they're affected by irrational ism
I when I talk about school prayer when I
talk about charitable choice I'm talking
about
of sectarianism in public life which is
something a little which is a different
kind of problem than the problem of how
our people thinking or not thinking what
is their notion of truth what is their
notion of knowledge the problem of
irrational ism I see affecting a whole
range of public policies I see it in
very clearly in our policies around
criminal justice which seemed to me
highly irrational and we don't have any
rational and almost no rational inform
debates about criminal justice policies
I used the example of the drug war and I
use it again and again because I think
that it is so glaring we've had this
supposed war on drugs for the last 25
years which is supposed to decrease drug
abuse it has had no appreciable effect
on drug usage instead it has greatly
increased the crime that's attendant on
illegal drug trafficking it has
contributed to the arms race in the
street it has overloaded our prisons
with low-level nonviolent offenders who
should not be in prison at all you know
it's been I think one of the biggest
public policy disasters over the last 25
years and it seems to me we have almost
no rational discussions about it because
a lot of people tend to look at drug use
of course you i should say use of some
drugs use of particular drugs as a vice
as a sin I mean there's a kind of
religious fervor to this drug war
instead of looking at as looking at it
as a medical problem or bad habit or
just a you know a social problem but but
not a sin and so it's very hard to have
rational discussions about it look what
happened to Joycelyn elders when she
simply suggested that maybe we could
think about studying the effects of
legalization you know was one of the
reasons that she lost her job so I
suppose if I could choose one area of
public policy in which i'd like to see
increased rationalism it would be the
whole area of criminal justice from the
reliance on the death penalty to the
over-reliance on prison for nonviolent
offenders and most of all to the war on
drugs and talk about prostitution do you
think that our policy on that is also
based on irrational sectarian ideas well
I don't think it's based on sectarian
ideas so much because i think that the
sense that prostitution is sinful is
probably shared by people across
different sects I've always thought
personally that prostitution ought to be
decriminalized there are certainly a lot
of you know as you probably know there
are feminist arguments on either side of
legalizing decriminalizing or
criminalizing prostitution that really
have nothing to do with religion that
have to do or with irrational ISM that
have to do with people's notions about
whether or not women in this culture or
in other cultures can actually consent
to prostitution whether or not as
possible to have prostitution without
coercion I happen to think that it is
possible you know in all functional ways
but I don't see that I don't see
prostitution as much as a I don't see
prostitution laws so much as sectarian
or even generally religious I think
abortion is much more so than
prostitution at the end of your talk you
advised that we should be careful about
where our information is coming from but
in the middle of your talk you refer to
some prohibition against establishment
of religion I suspect that you know that
the Constitution says Congress shall
enact no law respecting an establishment
of religion right but from what I know
I'm an engineer but I took a course in
the Supreme Court and the constant ocean
and it's clear that the intent was to
prevent Congress from interfering with
already established religious into at
least two states well the intent if you
know if you look at the writings of
Jefferson
manor road need to establish the intent
the intent was also to prevent the
country from becoming a theocracy and in
addition which in in addition because
the Constitution means not just what it
said 200 years ago the Constitution
means what the Supreme Court has said
that it means over the last 200 years
there's a lot of case law about the
Constitution the Constitution is ours to
debate and interpret and the way I
interpret the Constitution and the way a
lot of Supreme Court decisions have
interpreted the Constitution and the way
I think a lot of constitutional scholars
have interpreted the Constitution is to
say that the First Amendment does intend
to prevent state establishment of
religion it is it is intended in part to
prevent the state from the forbidding
its official stamp right i mean the
state in non-generic estate right except
that then there are other Supreme Court
decisions and other interpretations of
the Constitution that say that the
state's individually are subject to the
Bill of Rights well then my question is
as I understand Jerry Falwell and I used
to listen to him a lot he was on
television at seven in the morning he
felt that Christianity was under
endangered or under assault by secular
humanists the phrase he always used and
the argument was that the Supreme the
Constitution had been distorted I guess
by what he would probably have called
irrational interpretations such as yours
as opposed to the more well and he's
more rational so if the Supreme Court
next year decided that in fact really
they've been making a mistake in the
last hundred years with these you with
your interpretations and that the real
interpretation is that Congress can't
establish a religion but they can't
interfere with states establishing
religion which is what I think I think
it originally said would you that how
would you deal with that would you find
that irrational if that's what they
tried to do it seems to me that both of
these are
III think I understand your question how
would I feel I would find that wrong if
they did that I would think the Supreme
Court is wrong i think the Supreme Court
is often wrong I mean we all probably
think the Supreme Court is often wrong I
actually don't anticipate the court
doing that Jerry Falwell may say that
evangelical Christians are under siege
I'm not even sure Jerry Falwell believes
that I don't know what Jerry Falwell
believes and what Jerry Falwell says for
effect if I Jerry Falwell believes that
I think Jerry Falwell is wrong you know
it's it's become a common tactic among
some Christians some evangelical
Christians on the right to claim that
they are the victims of religious
discrimination one of the arguments that
I've heard I think Ralph Reed make in
favor of official school prayer is that
not to to say that official school
prayer is prohibited by the Constitution
is to discriminate against the people
who want to say the prayers and after
all we're just looking for our religious
rights our religious rights to say
prayers but you know that's a real
distortion of language they're not
looking for religious rights they're
looking for religious power they have
the right right now to say as many
prayers as they want as many federal
judges have pointed out students can
pray on the football field students can
pray in class silently to themselves
students can get together in groups and
say grace in the cafeteria before they
eat students can have their own
extracurricular religious organizations
that use school facilities there's a
really a great deal of religious freedom
for individual students that's allowed
in school what students don't have under
the Constitution is the power to make
other students pray and it seems to me
that that's what the proponents of
official school prayer were seeking they
were in seeking their religious rights
they were seeking the power to impose
their prayers on other students so you
know they can they can frame it however
they want that's not the way I frame it
I'd like to her a little more about your
thoughts on the causes of the rise of
rationality is this just basic human
nature and is this something cyclical
that if we wait 10 years new other
movements will arise or is it because of
specific failings of American culture
and education and political system all
of the above do you see any can you
identify any differences between a
rationality and in American culture and
other countries in the world yeah I
always stay away from making comparisons
between American culture and other
cultures because I just don't know where
their cultures well enough you know I i
know this culture fairly well because
I've lived here all my life and I've
thought about it and I have a sense
about it in my bones but I've never
lived abroad so I don't I just don't
know enough to answer that question and
to make the comparison but I'd be
interested to hear any thoughts that any
of you might have sort of the question I
wanted to ask the basic the causes of
the rise of rationalities if there's
such a thing and do you think the rise
of the visual media has anything to do
with that compared to print media isn't
it much much easier to to watch a movie
on critically rather than to read
something uncritically well I hesitate
to say that I think that film and video
can be quite thought-provoking I don't
think that it's a stupid medium I don't
think that you know I don't want to be
chauvinistic about this I don't think
that that reading and writing are
innately superior ornately more
sophisticated and I don't think that
I'll you know I think there are a lot of
things that you can find in national
magazines
that seemed to me a lot sillier a lot
less thought-provoking than some things
that you might find on TV so I don't
really think it's a question of the
medium it except perhaps to the extent
that we've become a very noisy culture
I've noticed and and I think that a lot
of noise interferes with concentration I
mean I'm old fashioned in that way and
and I'm not very good at blocking out a
lot of ambient noise I like quiet
peaceful places when i'm trying to think
or trying to read and there is something
about all this electronic media that
contributes to the noise and and i think
people it's quite insidious i'm not even
sure how much people are aware of it
because it becomes background noise you
know whether it's the televisions that
are on in the airport or in the elip now
they're in elevators you know they're
beginning to be televisions and
elevators or the piped in music in
different places you know that that
you're often being assaulted by a lot of
noise and I do think that that
interferes with our ability to think I'd
like to come back to the the impact of
irrational is Amon public life private
of rationalism manifesting itself in
public life I am I correct in assuming
that you see this as a dangerous
phenomenon dangerous somehow to our
democratic I think it's always I long
not to have informed rational discourse
about public policy issues because they
are complicated issues that require
evidence and a lot of empirical analysis
whether you're talking about what our
welfare policy should be or you know
what our criminal justice policy should
be how we should deal with children in
foster care we're not going to take
leaps of faith to figure out what the
policy should be we need to examine
what's go
going on we need to think about what are
the consequences one of the long-term
consequences of the steps we're going to
take now I mean takes a campaign finance
reform you know a lot of people might
have just a gut desire to somehow make
contributions illegal or to put caps on
them or to take caps off them because
all this money is just you know it's so
disturbing all this money in politics
but you really need to think about what
are the consequences of these reforms
going to be in one of the reasons that
were in so much trouble today with
campaign finance reform is that I think
there wasn't enough thought given to
what the consequences of the reforms 20
years ago we're going to be so yes I
think that in general the realm of
public policy is one where we ought to
be guided mostly by reason and by faith
only when it comes to articulating our
ideals but you know when we try to
figure out how to implement those ideals
we can't rely on faith we need to rely
on reason so what can we do to there's
my rationality out of the public realm
but what do you think we should do shall
we argue with people that I I always
enjoy arguing with people I find that's
always interesting I I don't have a
simple answer for you what what can we
do you know what I do is to talk about
it to write about it to talk about it
with other people and I'm open to
suggestions if you all think that
there's something more programmatic that
we can do yeah in the in the current
issue of the nation is a review by
Taylor branch on Garry wills new book I
haven't read it he points out that over
the last two decades which sort of
coincides with what you've been talking
about that the the common view among the
people has been turned around to look at
government as a necessary evil as
opposed to a necessary good and I wonder
whether perhaps the server ting of the
governmental function gives a lot of
license to a lot of these people come
out of the woodwork and say hey we'll
tell you how to write the Constitution
or how would she both sides of this
debate about whether the government is
good
government is evil because i think that
the government is alternately good and
evil i am pretty much an old-fashioned
liberal with a pretty strong attachment
to publicly funded social services I
think that the government should
intervene in the marketplace I don't
believe in the free market but I'm also
civil libertarian and so I have a lot of
mistrust of government I see the
government doing a lot to interfere with
privacy and individual freedom and
individual autonomy so I'm not sure that
it's entirely rational to look at the
government either as generally good or
generally evil because you know the
government is capable of being both I
think that we need to depend on it in
certain ways but I think we also need to
be very wary of it I think we should be
very wary of growing federal power we
should be very wary of growing federal
criminal jurisdiction one more question
Ames when you address cyber space in
your book did you also say anything
about email and how this affects the
interactions between people as well as
anything about people taking University
classes on the Internet no and if
there's something you'd like to say
about that we'd like to hear I was just
wondering if you thought that that would
contribute to irrational ism to in from
the inability to verify information I
don't think it has to I don't think it
has to you know somebody can lie to you
face-to-face or give you false
information face-to-face with almost as
much ease as they can do it on the
internets and the internet so I don't
think that it will necessarily lead to
misinformation but do you think that the
traditional classroom is better than a
classroom on the internet where everyone
just communicates via email yes but it
may be that classrooms on the internet
will draw in people who wouldn't have
been coming to traditional classrooms
anyway
hi I wonder if you haven't downplayed
the role of different forms of media
yourself pointed out that you get
televisions in elevators now well I mean
I can't imagine anyone actually leaving
a book in an elevator for someone to
read and I think it is because you can
absorb television in much smaller quanta
and i think i think the sort of
arguments you get on television we're
almost a bit ly kids you know did didn't
it didn't know that here is terrible and
that but the four eyes of TV allows that
and whereas books or other print media
tend not to like 10 not i think that's
true and i think that's an important
point i mean there's there's something
that I think of as the crossfire model
of debate which is you know one person
saying is to and the other person saying
is not when when producers look for
people to come on these shows they
invariably look for people with fairly
dogmatic simple polarized view so that
views so that when they interview you to
see if you should come on the show if
you qualify your response or your
position or if you try to be what I
think of as judicious they see that as
straddling or not having conviction or
waffling and you know for them not
waffling means you know is too is not
and in any case having these two very
simple clearly polarized positions is
simply considered better TV and it's
what people can digest it is it is
difficult to even speak in paragraphs
when you're on TV you know you can speak
in a couple of sentences and it's a you
have to speak in shorter sentences you
have to explain yourself in very simple
terms because people don't have time to
think about what you're saying at their
own pace you know they can't read a
sentence and stop and think about it and
then read the next one or maybe go back
they don't have the luxury of doing that
it keeps coming at them and they might
be doing other things while they're
watching and listening so that it's
you're right that it's it's it's not a
medium that lends itself to nuance
discussions of ideas you know you see it
once in a while on PBS I saw a
discussion on McNiel there I guess it's
not macneil/lehrer anymore but I still
think of it as McNeal air it's a couple
of weeks that maybe a week or so ago
when the AOL time warner merger happened
and they had this one guy who was a
media critic from San Francisco I wish I
could remember his name because he was
just terrific but what I what was most
remarkable about this man was that he he
went on for I don't know about four
minutes I mean he spoken like three full
paragraphs uninterruptedly Suarez who
was hosting the segment just let this
guy talk because he was quite articulate
he was saying something there were
fairly well constructed paragraphs and
ray Suarez let him talk and it was quite
remarkable I couldn't remember seeing
anybody talk for that you know for four
minutes whatever the time period was on
television in a long time that's it's
quite rare in this medium so I I think
you're right i think that making
television the venue of our public
debates does tend to debase them and it
tends to simplify them but I don't want
to romanticize what goes on in a lot of
books because there are I'll have a lot
of really crappy books out there that
are not much better than crossfire I'd
like to ask you one last question do you
see as a social observer and critic
juicy factors that point to the end of
this cycle and perhaps the decline of
the power of E rationalism not at the
moment but that doesn't mean they're not
there you just don't see them yeah well
I just don't see them yet no but I've
never been very good at predicting the
future you know it's the I mostly just
try to grapple with the present and
figure out what's going
not what will be and I don't think I'd
really want to know what the future had
in store for us i prefer for it to be a
mystery well thank you Wendy Kaminer
thank you
you